Quisiera dedicar esta canción a todas las mujeres sudafricanas;
a esas mujeres que no cedieron durante el apartheid.
Y, por supuesto, se la dedico también a mi abuela
que pienso realmente tuvo un papel muy importante
sobre todo en mi época de activista cuando era perseguido por la policía.
Ustedes recordarán que el 16 de junio de 1976 los estudiantes sudafricanos boicotearon
el idioma africaans por considerarlo un instrumento del opresor;
ya saben, tenían instrucciones
de hacer todo en africaans --
biología, matemáticas. ¿Y nuestros idiomas?
Los estudiantes querían hablar con el gobierno
pero la policía les respondió con balas.
Por eso cada 16 de junio conmemoramos
a todos aquellos camaradas o estudiantes que murieron.
Yo era muy pequeño, pienso que tenía 11 años,
y comencé a hacer preguntas.
Y así comenzó mi educación política
Más tarde ingresé a la organización juvenil que
era parte del Congreso Nacional Africano.
Entonces, mientras organizábamos algo,
una conmemoración, la policía nos cercaba,
ya saben, por considerarnos líderes.
Y yo solía huir de casa
cuando calculaba que ya vendría la policía,
cerca del 9 ó 10 de junio o así.
Pero mi abuela, saben, una vez dijo:
"No, mira, no vas a huir".
"Este es tu lugar y aquí te quedas".
Y, de hecho, vino la policía – porque nos arrestarían,
nos encarcelarían, para liberarnos cuando quisieran, después del 20 más o menos.
Fue así que el 10 de junio vinieron y rodearon la casa.
Mi abuela apagó todas las luces
y abrió la puerta de la cocina.
Y les dijo: "Vusi está aquí pero esta noche no se lo van a llevar".
"Estoy cansada de que vengan aquí a acosarnos...
mientras sus hijos duermen tranquilos en sus casas".
"Él está aquí y ustedes no se lo van a llevar".
“Tengo agua hirviendo lista para el primero que se acerque".
Y se fueron.
(Aplausos)